It is being a while since we were with Athena. So let us get back to talking
about her life. Now Athena lives in California, in the Bay area to be exact. To
tell a more about you, here is the Pacific Ocean and here is West of
California. Here is San Francisco Bay. It is a pretty beautiful area to live
in. And she goes to school in Saint Jose Bay right down here. And all of these
little cities lie right along the bay now, sometimes Athena likes to take a
non-stop train from San Jose, all the way up to San Francisco, which is this
northern city right here. Along the train line, which I have drawn in red right
here, are a bunch of other stations. Including Sunnyvale, Mount View, Palo
Alto, Redwood City, San Mateo and Millbrae. So, let me ask you a question. If
Athena wants to take that nonstop train starting in San Jose and going all the
way up to San Francisco, which stations must the train pass through along the
way? Remember the red path here is the train track. It doesn't branch off
anywhere. it just follows this path exactly.